[Musique]
alors voilà un film qui a coûté très
cher est un film très riche où il ya
beaucoup de monde il ya beaucoup de
couleurs qui s'appelle les demoiselles
de rochefort de jacques demy l'auteur
des parapluies de cherbourg dont il faut
tout de même que nous parlions je crois
qu'on va annoncer la couleur dans
l'oubli j'ai beaucoup de plaisir et
beaucoup de plaisir mais c'est le
brillant m'ont aussi chevaux et ça c'est
la création c'est la tendance tout à
l'heure
patrick rambaud l'a pas vu c'est trop
sucré trop sucrés oui pour vous c'est
une fois que vous avez bord benayoun moi
j'aime bien le poire mais je trouve ce
film merveilleux attendais pas mais moi
aussi
ah bon vous l'aurez tous non elle n'a
pas pu y a que vous qui êtes contre je
suis comme je suis même pas contre non
alors allez-y parlerais pas le succès à
l'isic d'abord premièrement le texte
mais je trouvais qu'il était
complètement idiot c'est gênant quand
même c'est sous ces bêtes
et puis les trop bien fait ce film we
pas simple intel annonce une orange ne
sont pas tous à croire des torrents
lorsque murray jo avec son voisin une
chemise violette et puis vous avez des
détails par exemple c'était poussé
jusqu'à la maniaquerie par exemple vous
avez les soeurs dorléac qui ont un grain
de beauté dans le dos exactement au même
endroit c'est rarement c'est être
charmant vraiment j'aurais préféré jouer
un peu plus de force et moins deux
points de moins grande beauté
[Applaudissements]
démolition monsieur parce qu'après ils
vont tout reconstruire un les noms
j'aime j'aime pas tellement le rose hill
et parapluies vous aviez aimé j'ai
préféré les parachutistes
non non c'est pas c'est pas le mélange
dans le bas du mélo dans nos hôtels et
rochefort j'ai beaucoup aimé la fin la
rencontre du langage des vidéos de stock
enfin chercher devant l'assemblée qu'est
ce qu'on attend que le début et on joue
accord mais c'est vraiment trompe
attendu c'est vraiment au mieux non
c'est pas inattendu c'est inévitable il
développe bien fait comme michel c'est
là où vous aurez peut être le mélo
horrible oui bon à côté moi j'adore ce
film maintenant j'aimerais qu'on en dise
du bien
moi ce qui me touche c'est justement pas
très bien fait monsieur est un truc tout
excès que le pic au lit dans ce pas très
bien en nous penchant sur cd s'est créé
depuis cinq ans les deux filles il ya
des moments où elles sont pas très bien
photographier le gabon d'un coup un côté
humain il ya un espèce de côté
attendrissant qui intervient dans la
comédie musicale qui avait et qui avait
été toujours une perfection notamment la
comédie musicale américaine est qu on a
même la visite du dieu de la comédie
musicale américaine c'est un peu vieilli
lui qui est un peuple est justement ce
qui est touchant c'est oui un vieux
monsieur maintenant et moi ce qui me
touche et les imperfections ce film et
que c'est le sujet il n'est pas
évidemment et cesser ces six personnages
il suffirait qu'il traverse la rue que
danielle darrieux traversé la rue pour
tomber sur pick y aurait pas comment
fabriquer des pâtes comédie musicale
c'est le côté justement un parfait cette
espèce de côté toujours vulnérable
fragile
ce que j'aime moins en revanche c'est
peut-être la musique de michel legrand
ça mais sinon je filerai plus hachée par
le côté imparfait par le côté sans cesse
remis à christian jacques ferron
heureusement ils aiment le film non mais
non mais la raison c'est beaucoup plus
humain jean louis borie va alors même je
souscris à terme à ce que les émissions
ne brillant pas ce qu'est ce qui m'a
frappé c'est le côté béquille de janis
kelly béquille moral oui et alors on
sent que et c'est là où ça m'a gêné
c'est un film au fait que kim a j'étais
heureux pendant deux heures ce qui est
extrêmement agréable et ce qui m'a gêné
simplement c'est que étant donné le
genre la comédie musicale ce que j'aurai
reproché à demi c'est une espèce de une
certaine sagesse c'est que justement il
ya une espèce de respect et qui étaient
représentés par une phase de déférence à
l'égard de john kelly et que là elle
aurait pu vraiment tout envoyer en l'air
parce que quand on repart aux fort bien
par exemple que ça s'arrête
et alors et là ils étaient tenus et ils
respectent certains c'était la règle
d'or que mon avis n'en connaît pas à si
ce n'est qu'à la fantaisie la plus
débridée la plus la plus démente et la
plus dingue
alors là il y a j'ai reproché un peu en
deçà de ce qu'ils pourraient faire mais
compte tenu le saas est constamment joli
à voir c'est extrêmement agréable à
entendre avec un peu de monotonie et
tous les gens sont ravis ce sans fin la
marine nationale
allez voir c'est absolument incroyable
tous oxygénée tous les drapeaux thalazur
etc mais là ce qu'on dit c'est un film
sur le bonheur je trouve pas que ce soit
un film sur le bonheur c'est un film sur
la mélancolie parce que ces trois
couples
quand le film va être terminés ils vont
être certainement malheureux comme des
bières ils sont absolument pas accorder
les essais ça ce qui est touchant c'est
à bonn reste qu'ils cherchent pour
arriver à la catastrophe
mais le lendemain que c'est en ça que
demi et fidèle tout de même son cinéma
c'est une comédie musicale
aux lois du genre etc mais c'est aussi
dans le film qui est le plus près du
monde qui a quatre cas décrits et
invente et demi car c'est un film sur
les rendez vous manqués exactement
l'histoire de lola c'est pas simplement
un ressort de votre ville un resort de
feydeau que tous ces personnages se
croisent sans se rencontrer pour se
rencontrer finalement comme par hasard
au dernier moment
et d'ailleurs ce raté ensuite
vraisemblablement mais c'est que c'est
justement un univers que décrit que
décrit demi qui est le sien et cet
univers-là toujours centré dans un port
toujours basé sur le déracinement sur la
fuite de ses personnages car chacun si
des gens se raconte pas ce qu'il se fût
eux-mêmes perpétuellement c'est qu'ils
sont toujours en train de rêver à
quelque chose qu'ils n'ont pas ça c'est
un peu plus que de la comédie musicale
finalement oui alors que les lois du
genre soient respectés que le film soit
merveilleusement filmer car moi je
trouve qu'il est très bien fait que
justement idée digne de certains grands
films américains tirent une grande
comédie musicale américaine ça c'est une
chose qui saute aux yeux mais je crois
que le que l'auteur reste fidèle à son
monde à travers ce genre n'est pas à
proprement parler le sien mais qu'il
s'est approprié complètement qu'il a
véritablement reconquis à la force du
poignet je trouve que ça c'est admirable
effacé respectable bon là j'approuve
vraiment benayoun de souligner dire ce
que tout le monde négliger jette par
dessus bord c'est justement l'humanité
des scénarios de d'amis on dit que ce
sont des livres et de
ira pas du tout les personnages sont
plus passionnant que dans beaucoup de
films dramatiques et je crois que ça
c'est un peu le rôle de danielle
darrieux par exemple et bien construites
ou votre habilité personnel est nominé
il interprété par une jeune carrière
extraordinaire fille vous trouvez pas
qu'elle est absolument beran temps ça
c'est la vrai lion simple aux côtés des
libériennes un génial jerome robbins à
elle et elle est très inégale c'est à
dire qu'on se dit au début quand il ya
les deux petites danseuses anglaise on
se dit ça va être catastrophique pour
les soeurs dorléac heureusement les
escamote elles reviennent à la fin sa
folle danse pas beaucoup chacun dans
selon son tempérament et ses peluches
aux dominical d'employés aux manières de
le mariage de béjart et demi ça me
paraît tout à fait tâche oui oui nous
fait passer des frissons dans le dos
l'un c'est parfait enfin tout le monde
aime ça les jeunes les vieux dans tout
seul là pour le soutenir un petit peu
warrants celi à a dit que c'était une
pilule de bonheur et choqué quand même
un peu ce côté là et quand il ya eu
cette débauche de rose bonbon je vois
pas pourquoi demi aime tellement le rose
bonbon je prétendais c'est la couleur et
dragées quand on voit tout d'un coup
arriver les bonnes soeurs en temps je
vais jamais en pèlerinage à lourdes
brusquement jeudi a enfin du noir enfin
quelque chose en concert près de 10
et j'ai dis vive les bonnes soeurs et on
les a ridiculisé j'ai trouvé ça très
triste parce qu'au fond tout d'un coup
là quand il ya tellement de bonheur
j'aime j'aime un peu de s'injecter ce
qui est très frappant c'est infime
difficilement atteint grimpe les visites
infime que ceux qui aiment ne rendent
pas plus aimable en en parlant non c'est
à dire que c'était un film au fond qu'il
faut voir et non il ne faut pas parler
on aimera ou on aimerait en s'inscrivant
lauriers mais oui mais oui vous êtes un
intellectuel complètement tordus vous
allez sommet les hindous font des
comédies musicales sont atroces oui ils
vont allez allez vous allez voir ça
[Musique]